ROHITH RAMKUMAR:
Welcome, everyone.
For our session today,
I'm going to talk
about what we've been working
on in Google networking
to increase speed, reliability,
the locations you can connect
to us, and, of course, how
to manage those connections.
We'll also cover our recently
announced partnership
with Cisco bringing
together SD-WAN
and the best of GCP cloud.
Starting with our dedicated
Interconnect product
at Next 2019 last year, we
announced beta availability
for the 100 gigabit per
second dedicated Interconnect.
Since then, it's become
generally available.
100 gigabits per second
dedicated Interconnect
provides 10 times the capacity
of our previous Interconnect
offering and can be combined
into link aggregation groups
to bring massive
amounts of bandwidth.
With 100 gigabit per second
dedicated Interconnect,
you can scale your
connection capacity
to meet your particular
requirements,
connect up to 800 gig
transport circuits
for private cloud
traffic to Google Cloud
at any of our POPs.
We're also working on increasing
packet per second performance
and making it easier to achieve
high SLA configurations.
There will be more news
on this later this year.
Although Google already
has enormous footprint,
we want to make it easier
and less expensive than ever
for customers to
connect to GCP globally.
So we're aiming to
bring Interconnect
to over 30 more locations
worldwide by mid next year.
When we're done with
the expansion program,
we will have brought
the number of locations
you can connect to
GCP to well over 100,
adding 50% more
locations in key places,
like Houston, Boston,
Berlin, Canberra,
and multiple locations in
Asia and the Middle East.
Finding a suitable location
for you to connect to Google
is made easier through our
extensive partner ecosystem.
You can now find the
optimum connectivity pathway
to Google Cloud platform from
any on-net building or data
center worldwide on the
new Cloud Pathfinder
app for Google Cloud
provided by [? Cloudseek. ?]
By enabling customers
like you with an app,
like Cloud Pathfinder
for Google Cloud,
we've provided a
search-based interface
to make it easy to identify
which partners can provide
Interconnect connectivity
at points closest to you
on-prem to GCP.
The app is available from all
mobile devices or your desktop.
You can access the app for
free now via find.cloud/google.
Moving onto our
Cloud VPN product,
if your needs are to
securely connect everywhere,
you can use GCP's Cloud VPN.
Our newest offering,
High Availability VPN,
became generally available
in Q4 of last year.
With HA VPN, you can connect
to your on-premises GCP
or other cloud environments
with an industry-leading SLA
of four nines catered for your
mission-critical workloads.
With redundant tunnel
pairs, the extra nine
takes you from eight hours and
46 minutes of allowed downtime
per year to just 53 minutes.
That's a 90% reduction
in allowed downtime.
We're encouraging customers
to migrate their deployments
from classic to
HA VPN to achieve
a more reliable architecture.
We've briefly covered
Google's network and the work
we've done to expand
the locations to connect
increasing the speed and
making your connections
secure and available.
Now, we'd like to zoom out
a bit and talk about not
just connecting to
GCP, but the ability
to connect to places outside
of GCP using Google's backbone.
And we're doing this initially
in partnership with Cisco.
Here's a little video that
shares a little bit more
about the partnership we've
been working on with Cisco.
- The network is the foundation
of hybrid and multi-cloud
business transformation.
You need a turnkey solution to
securely bridge applications
to networks across
multiple clouds,
modernize your enterprise, and
reduce networking complexity
with the best of Cisco
and Google Cloud.
Our joint solution
will automatically
provision a reliable
global network that
grows with your
needs, experience
simple and flexible
customer network access,
publish all of your
services in one place,
and seamlessly extend and tend
to enterprise applications,
deliver context aware and
identity-based security
management, realize a
fully software-defined
end-to-end network.
Get to know Cisco SD-WAN
Cloud Hub with Google Cloud.
ROHITH RAMKUMAR:
So what we know is
that customers are increasingly
moving into the realities
of a multi-cloud world.
Many surveys of
Enterprise customers
suggest that enterprises are
deploying their applications
increasingly across
multiple clouds.
We believe that this is the
enterprise modernization
and digital
transformation journey.
And it starts with
the network which
must enable agile access to
innovation promised by cloud,
as well as simplified models
for multi-cloud, multi-platform
deployments.
The network must evolve to
provide agility, simplicity,
and openness that is needed
to power this transformation.
To summarize, what we're seeing
is enterprises that are broadly
looking to create, connect,
and consume resources
across a number of
different environments,
creating them, leveraging the
best in-class technologies,
connecting them
from a single point,
and consuming them
on demand, including
the connectivity between them.
When deployments span
multiple app environments,
enterprises need to maintain a
fairly precise set of controls.
The joint solution
from Cisco and Google
addresses exactly these needs,
bringing the best of SD-WAN
together with the
intelligence of cloud in order
to enhance application
performance
and end user experience.
What we're continuing
to see is a shift
from monolithic
architectures of legacy apps
on private on-prem
datacenter environments
to a microservices
architecture that are
deployed in and across clouds.
We're also seeing an increase
in the use of top tier SaaS
applications becoming more
central to maintaining
enterprise productivity.
The use of SD-WAN in
concert with cloud network
and intelligence across
these environments
means that corporate policies
and security postures
can be maintained even as
the application delivery
footprint changes.
To further joint
interest, Google and Cisco
are expanding our partnership
through a unique solution
called Cisco SD-WAN Cloud
Hub with Google Cloud.
We will enable
200,000 enterprises
to access the power of
Cisco's SD-WAN solution
extending it to GCP's cloud
while powering connectivity
over Google's network,
supporting new capabilities
such as allowing enterprises to
use Google's global network as
if it were their own.
We've seen a number
of publications
already begin to detail
the power and potential
of the cloud hub solution,
as Cisco and Google integrate
SD-WAN and cloud to deliver
a unique value to customers.
A few of those
publications and quotes
have been shared on the slide.
At a high level, with
the cloud hub solution,
enterprises can continue to
deploy their Cisco SD-WAN
footprint on-prem and via the
Cisco vManage solution extended
to, through, and within GCP
leveraging Google's network
to enhance connectivity
to things like their VPC
environment, third-party
SaaS services, and solutions
and other clouds.
Here, we see three major pillars
of benefits for the cloud hub
solution related to flexibility
and simplicity, improved end
user experience, and risk
and compliance management.
With the cloud hub
solution, connectivity
from on-prem to the
cloud hub is provisioned
in an automated fashion via
Cisco's vManaged controller
while capacity to the cloud hub
is provided on demand as well
as beyond the cloud
hub and how the cloud
hub accesses resources that
sit on cloud and beyond.
Cisco Cloud Hub
essentially enables
elastic and dynamic
consumption of bandwidth
over Google's network.
With service
directory, applications
can then be listed and have its
metadata shared with the SD-WAN
fabric so that the appropriate
delivery treatment can
be provided via the SD-WAN for
each application specifically.
Also, from a
security perspective,
Cisco and Google
share the user context
to enhance the
ability for the SD-WAN
to maintain the appropriate
levels of access
to cloud apps and services.
For example,
sharing such context
would allow access to be
blocked for a user connected
to a guest network within
a corporate environment
while accepting access
to apps running on cloud
for legitimate corporate users.
Going into the solution
component specifically,
Cisco establishes a
presence in Google
at the relevant regions based
on the customer's deployment
needs.
From there, the
cloud hub solution
can leverage Google's network
to connect to other cloud hubs
to enable transit and
hybrid connectivity.
But cloud hubs will also be able
to access the customer's VPC
environments and various
applications and services that
are relevant to the customer.
Speaking of applications
and services,
enterprises can leverage service
directory through cloud hub
in order to access a
catalog and publish
a list of apps and
their properties,
like the need for low latency
transmission to the end user.
From here, Cisco's
vManage retrieves
this information shared via
metadata on a per application
basis and then
enables the cloud hubs
to take the appropriate
traffic steering decisions
based on what's required
for a given application.
Lastly with the Cisco Cloud
Hub and Google Cloud SD-WAN,
they shared contextual access to
corporate user and app identity
to be able to provide
enhanced access to the most
secure segments of
the enterprise network
to better manage risk
and maintain compliance.
To summarize,
Google and Cisco are
in a strategic
collaboration to build
what we believe will
be the industry's
first application-centric
multi-cloud fabric.
We believe this will help change
the model by which enterprises
choose to connect to
the resources that
matter to them the most.
In this solution, Google
provides reliable connectivity
over its network bridging
the enterprise network
to cloud applications and
services on GCP and beyond.
Thank you.